- [Mark] All right, Heather.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Heather. Oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Heather] Originally,
I'm from Detroit, Michigan.
I grew up in Brooklyn, New York.
And now I'm in Los Angeles.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
- I have a big Italian family,
and most of them are still in New York.
We are from Sicily, originally.
And, basically I have three
sisters and one brother,
and a single mother.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- Turmoil.
My mother was an alcoholic,
and I basically took care
of my two younger siblings.
And she was abusive.
So, it was hectic at most.
- [Mark] What kind of abuse?
- Physical.
She drank a lot.
And became very violent.
And because I was the
only one in the house,
I was the target of that violence.
- [Mark] And you went through high school?
- I did, but I did not graduate.
I went to...
I left my house when I was 16
with Job Corps.
I graduated from Job Corps
and got married at 17.
And had four children.
- [Mark] You have four kids?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And you raise them?
- I did up until my oldest was 13
and they got removed from my care.
- [Mark] How did that go about?
- I just had a lot of baggage.
I came out here and...
- [Mark] How is the marriage?
- It wasn't good.
I mean, I was 17.
My mom pretty much gave me away to him.
He was 23 years old.
And wasn't a good marriage at all.
But, I had nowhere else
to go, so I stayed.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff
went on in the marriage?
- A lot of abuse.
He was just very abusive.
- [Mark] So physical?
- Yeah. And mentally
Oh.
It was just not,
you shouldn't get married at 17.
You are not even an adult at the age.
And,
- [Mark] Is that what
got you to come to LA?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Okay.
- I left.
I think I was 20, 23, 24
years old, when I left
and came out here
didn't know anybody.
Wanting to get far away
and stayed at the mission,
the Union Rescue Mission.
And that's when my children
got removed from me.
And that's when I started
with the drug abuse.
I was on Hydrocodone since I
was 17 because I have Lupus.
So, they basically just said,
you have a terminal illness
and we're gonna make you
as comfortable as possible.
So they put me on
Hydrocodone at 17 years old.
I go through 80 pills in two weeks.
At this point, because my body has built
up such an immune system that I can't...
it doesn't take full effect with me.
And without those pills,
I go through withdrawals.
And when I go through withdrawals
and I can't get the hydrocodone,
I started seeing a man out here,
and he was on sherm.
I didn't know what sherm was,
never did it before.
And, so I started with the sherm.
At first, it was every now and again,
when I didn't have my pills.
And then it got more frequent
because just like the
pills it is addictive.
I got to a point where
I almost got kicked out
of my apartment when I lived over at...
'cause I used to live over here
where my friend Gigi stays now
and I almost got kicked out
because me and him were doing it so much.
It puts you in a daze
where you really don't know
what you're doing.
You're almost stagnant,
because you're so high
you stay frozen or you just freak out.
It puts you in a
different type of reality.
Recently, I did it and I
was staying at the Hayward
and I was out front
because he's not allowed
in the building anymore
because of our drug use.
And I was so high that
I really thought that
I was in this like daze
that I thought that
the world was coming to an end.
I just had this foreboding feeling
and I kinda flipped out.
And I ran away from him.
And just a lot of things
could have happened to me.
But thank God that they didn't.
Because I was so high.
Because without my hydrocodone,
that's the only thing that
helps with my withdrawals.
I get very sick when I don't have them.
And, as sometimes I go back to my doctor
and try to get more and he supplies it.
So I take 'em.
I mean, I've been taking
them since I was 17
and there's no way I can stop
taking them at this point.
Because if I don't, I get sick.
And I need a substitute.
And sherm's my substitute
and I can't stop because
without it, I get ill.
Like right now I ran out.
And, I'm trying to get
enough money to get sherm.
That's what I do.
- [Mark] So, the pills are your preference
or is it the sherm?
- The pill's my preference
but when I don't have them,
I go to sherm.
- Right.
- I've done crystal before,
but I can't do that because it
makes my heart race too much.
And I become short of breath.
My Lupus,
it seems like
with the pills, has attacked my body more.
I've had a kidney removed.
I've been on dialysis
and I don't stop because I can't.
I have to have them.
I mean, there's no other...
there's nothing else
more to say I have to.
My body now is so addicted to
them that if I don't take it
I will be ill.
Regardless how it's affected my body,
regardless how it's affected my Lupus.
I do have seizures.
I've had seizures when I took in sherm.
And I still do.
I have to.
- [Mark] And your kids are where?
- They're in foster care.
They actually got adopted out.
I do see my 18 year
old daughter sometimes.
She knows that there's a difference in me,
but she doesn't know the reason
I did not share this with her.
And I won't.
It's just depression on
top of everything else.
It's my only escape from reality.
So, I do it.
And there is no stopping.
- [Mark] And how are you
supporting yourself now?
- I get SSI.
I use that money to support my habit.
I get pills from my doctor.
He supplies the the hydrocodone.
80 pills are gone within two weeks,
sometimes a week.
Because I take them constantly.
Because I'm so immune to them now
I have to take at least eight
in one day, if not more.
And it's causing problems with my liver,
but, I can't stop.
And I'm not going to.
I have to, I have to, it's a need.
I have to take them.
Because if I don't, like
I said, I get very ill.
I go through withdrawals,
and with everything else,
I don't want to be sick.
- [Mark] Looking at your situation now.
What do you think?
What would you point a finger at to...
- The doctors.
Because, instead of caring for my illness,
they pretty much gave up on me and said,
I'm just gonna make her
comfortable until she dies.
They gave me to the age of
45 before my body gives out.
So, at this point,
I'm basically saying,
well I'm gonna die anyway.
So, I might as well be comfortable.
So that's why I do it.
The doctors, they don't care.
Especially when you
have a terminal illness
all they want to do is
make you comfortable.
And that's it.
They don't really check to
see how your condition is.
They don't see you deteriorating.
And you take it as they don't care.
So why should you?
- [Mark] This has gotta be
impressing for you, right?
- It is very.
And that just makes me want to do it more.
- [Mark] Right.
Because I feel like, if nobody
else cares, why should I?
So I do it and I'm going
to continue doing it
because if I'm going to die,
I'm not gonna be in pain.
I feel bad because,
my children.
when they do come of age and I'm not here.
I wonder what people say about me.
What they will hear.
But the same time,
I don't want to be in pain.
I've gone through enough of that.
My body has betrayed me.
I feel so...
And then on top of that, I
feel like I'm just alone.
So, why not make myself comfortable?
Why not ease that pain?
Cause I'm in constant pain
from the lupus and seizures.
People don't understand.
They don't know what
lupus does to a person.
Especially when you
have it since you're 17.
You have organs being removed,
because the lupus is attacking it.
And you're in constant pain.
And the doctors don't care.
And all they want to do is
hear shove some pills
and take these and buy.
They don't even check to
see how your condition is
until something comes so severe
that an organ has to be removed.
And to me, they failed me.
- [Mark] Do you ever look at the
childhood abuse that you endured
and then the marriage that you had,
and how that kind of...
- That, affects me a lot.
- [Mark] Created a whole
series of problems.
- Yes.
Not with just the drug abuse,
but with relationships.
The one that I was doing
sherm with was abusive.
I almost got shot in the
head because we were so high
and he was playing with a gun
and it got this much close to my head.
And I could have died.
And we were just so high.
I just didn't care.
It's just, a lot to take
in just for one person.
Not just to mention with my health issues,
with my family.
I'm very distant with them.
I don't really talk to them.
I'm not close with them.
So I'm pretty much alone.
My children were the only thing I had.
And when they took that away from me,
I just didn't care anymore.
So, I just take as many
pills as I need to.
And, when I don't have them,
I go to sherm.
I've done cocaine before.
It doesn't do anything to me because,
I guess my metabolism is so used to
the high amounts of hydrocodone.
It really other drugs don't affect me.
Other than sherm
because of what sherm is.
So, basically it's just those two things.
I've tried other things because,
I wanted a different outlet,
and it doesn't work with me.
- [Mark] sherm is PCP?
- Yes.
- And is that a good substitute
for the pills that you can't afford?
- Yes.
Because of how strong it is.
It makes the pain go away.
It doesn't last very long as the pills do.
But it lasts as long enough
for me to forget that I'm in pain.
- [Mark] You smoke it, right?
- Yes. So a cigarette is basically liquid
in a very small capsule.
And you take the cigarette
and you dip it in the bottle
and you smoke it.
And that's how it's adjusted.
And then shortly after that,
you go through a whole like
anesthesia moment where you you feel like
you're in a different realm
or your mind just wanders,
but it can be very dangerous
because you you're like
almost stagnant or frozen.
Your whole body.
Everything's frozen.
There was a time that I've done it.
And I was in an elevator
for like 20 minutes
because, I didn't realize I was there.
You basically, your body is frozen
your mind's somewhere else.
So, you kind of escape your whole body
and you go to a different state of mind.
- [Mark] And I'm sure you see that
you're in a very self-destructive...
- [Heather] Yes.
But, at this point in time,
I don't care.
Because, everyone else has given up on me
that it made me give up on myself.
And I feel as though that's
the only thing that's
I can actually turn to at this time.
And, it's the only thing
that's kind of getting me
out of my thoughts and
taking me somewhere else.
I have a pain out of all
thinking about all this
stuff that I think about.
- [Mark] Yeah, but being apart
from your kids must be...
That'd be enough to
break any woman, right?
- [Mark] Yes.
- [Heather] It's the only thing that's
taking my mind off that.
- [Mark] Do you still talk to your kids?
- [Heather] No. Only
my oldest daughter 18.
I haven't talked to my
children in almost four years.
My oldest son is 20 and doesn't
want anything to do with me.
He was taken from me when he was 14.
And now he's 20.
And then my daughter.
- [Mark] So the drug use
started for you at what age?
- [Heather] My drug use started at 23.
- [Mark] And how old are you now?
- [Heather] I'm 39.
- [Mark] So when your kids were young
you were playing around with drugs too.
- [Heather] Yeah.
Because of the pain that I was in.
I was on the pills before
I even had children.
And when they were born,
I didn't stop taking them.
I continued to take them.
I didn't really start the sherm until
after they were taken though.
I was only here a few months
before they were taken.
And right after that, I
was introduced to sherm.
And that's when that began
and I have not stopped yet.
It's been about five or six years now
since I've been doing it.
- [Mark] What's the biggest mistake?
What's your biggest regret?
- Getting married at the young
age that I was married in.
Having children with the wrong man
and coming out here.
Because before this,
other than the pills,
I had no interest in doing different drugs
and things like that.
And then I came out here, things happened
and I went full force.
Not caring about the consequences.
I still, at this point don't care
because I just feel like,
with a terminal illness that I have,
I rather die not being in pain
and not being depressed all the time.
Than, to be in pain
and to be hurt emotionally.
Who wants to die like that?
So, that's why I do it.
- [Mark] What is the most
important thing you've learned
in your life?
- I don't even think I've learned it yet.
I don't think I've learned it yet.
To be honest.
Because if I did,
I wouldn't be doing these drugs, right?
- [Mark] Right.
- I haven't learned it yet.
And hopefully it will.
I know I'm being self-destructive.
I acknowledge that.
But, with everything that happens to me,
or have had had happened to me,
you come to a point
where you just give up.
And I think that's what I did.
I gave up.
Gave up on myself and on my life.
There is no going back from that.
You get in so deep emotionally
and physically that there's a point where
you can't come back from it.
And, I think I've reached that point.
I've actually tried to commit suicide
more than once.
Because I couldn't take it.
It just wouldn't stick, I guess.
So, I guess I'm just
self-destructive this way.
And there's no coming back from it.
So I do what I do.
I'm just hoping that when I am gone,
my children will learn about who I was
when they wasn't around.
That's my only hope.
And that's my only regret is that
they find out
how their mother screwed up so much.
- [Mark] What would you say to your kids,
if God forbid,
something like that happened.
And your kids watch this video
- That.
it's not their fault.
And.
That I left them.
And I never wanted this to happen.
But it did.
And you have choices.
You have to live with those choices.
And hopefully they make the right ones.
Because I didn't.
And I can't go back.
- [Mark] All right, Heather.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] I wish you lots of luck.
- [Mark] Are you going
to the women's center?
Over at 5th and San Pedro?
- [Heather] No.
- [Mark] You didn't want to go over there.